There's a,
there's a weird ideology that they're attached to that is,
it's,
it's not tenable.
It's not,
you can't argue it,
you know,
the idea of ethical treatment of animals,
I'm 100% with that.
I fucking hate the whole idea of captive orchids.
That to me is one of the big rows that freaks me the fuck out.
That we can take these alien creatures that are essentially as smart as us
probably,
and put him in swimming pools and justify it.
And that the only time they've ever killed people in recorded history has been
in those swimming pools.
They don't kill people in the wild.
They kill everything else.
They killed whales,
they killed dolphins,
they kill sharks.
They don't fuck with people.
In fact,
there's been instances where they've saved people and yet we've decided to put
those.
So me and Peter are on the hundred percent,
the same page as that.
Pete has retweeted a bunch of shit that I've put up before,
which is really weird.
They retweeted a bunch of shit that I've put up about,
you know,
about,
uh,
orcas.
And when I've done that,
people like,
uh,
you know,
he hunts,
right.
And then,
then it gets,
you know,
radio silence,
they don't want to comment on that.
They just want to support my hate for,
you know,
Orca Kevin.
Yeah.
You know,
I had,
um,
one of the most,
I've had some,
I've been fortunate to have remarkable engagements with wildlife in my life.
But two years ago in NBC,
I had one with a killer whale.
And it was,
it was wicked.
And to this day,
I regret not making the decision I'm about to tell you about,
but we had been,
um,
I'd been bear hunting on the coast and we were in a boat cruising back to the
harbor and we found two pods of killer whales,
uh,
three big bowls and a bunch of cows that were hunting.
And,
uh,
we kept as they would come up,
they were chasing salmon and as they would come up,
we've just get closer just to film them or even just to see them and then they'd
go down.
And so,
I don't know if it was just happenstance of where we were,
but we came up and we were just kind of waiting for the whole pod to come up and
all of a sudden,
just 50 feet from the boat.
Here comes the huge dorsal fin of this bowl,
comes right at our boat,
bumps into our boat.
I'm standing on the,
in the crow's nest,
essentially I'm on the roof of the boat looking at this saying he comes up,
bumps into our boat and he just glides his left side all along the boat.
So his left pectoral fin is probably under our gunnel,
if you will,
or under our hall.
And so he's just dragging his Finn and he rotates on his side,
dragging his dorsal fin along our side exhales covering,
I'm our director of photography Williams face in his spray.
And as he's doing this,
he goes,
he hugs the bowel of our boat and he never ever breaks eye contact with me.
He's staring at me out of his left eye,
literally rolling his eye over and he just cruises all the way around the boat.
And,
uh,
I wanted to dive in and I just wasn't sure.
Like I didn't want to be one of these,
you got to die.
I didn't want to be the first guy to diet.
And I also didn't want to have like some sort of shallow water blackout because
the water was so cold.
So I didn't want to dive in and have all of a sudden,
like I didn't know how my body would react cause I hadn't been in the water yet.
And so,
um,
and then also I was like,
I,
you know,
I'd watched black fish or whatever that film is really killed a bunch of folks
that you know,
in,
in a seaworld and in NBC.
And so I was just like,
well,
what if you know,
there's gotta be at first,
you know,
wolves never killed anyone any either.
And then,
you know,
some young lady went jogging and BC and son of a bitch.
We have number one.
Well,
there's a long history of will's coop killing people though in the past.
I'm just saying,
you know,
like,
in recorded time,
but it was still,
it was,
it was a,
and he maintained eye contact turned and then just continued on with the hunt.
But it was the film all this,
well,
you filmed as much as we could because it happened really fast.
But yeah,
it was wicked.
Absolutely wicked.
I mean,
literally his,
you know,
his dorsal fins probably 10 feet tall and it is just,
when you drag something against another on in an object with force,
you know,
it's vintage.
You know,
he was just very engaged with the boat as a dorsal fin.
Really?
That tall.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's gotta be eight,
nine,
10 feet.
That's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
I guess it makes sense.
They're so big.
Fuck man.
I've never seen one in the wall.
I've seen dolphins in the wall and I've seen whales in the wild.
I've never seen an Orca.
Yeah.
Their weight,
I mean wicked animals.
We don't even,
we can't even comprehend what that animal's head,
that if orchids weren't real and big foot was real,
we wouldn't give a shit about big foot,
big foot who'd be in the zoo right next to the fucking orangutans.
You know,
we'd be like,
look at the big monkey,
stupid monkey,
you know?
Yeah.
But orcas,
I mean,
they speak in a language that we can't decipher.
We don't know what they're saying,
but we know that they have dialects.
We know that they stay in these pods for life.
They,
they,
they have this family organization and they all stay in their clan there.
They're fucking incredible.
And you've seen,
you've seen black fish,
obviously.
Yeah.
I,
as much as I could watch,
I could watch the whole thing and I get angry.
I get,
I get furious that this is a giant business,
that they take these things and they buy them from other organizations.
And I've had,
you know,
I just,
I've had real problems with it for a long time.
And,
um,
I felt my friend Phil Demars,
he was a,
a a trainer at marine land and he's been on the podcast many,
many times and he's involved in these constant lawsuits with Bahrain land.
Um,
he was a walrus trainer and he also trained killer whales and you know,
he's given us some real insight into the horrors of what it's like in marine
land and even in seaworld and what they're doing and how they,
how they get these orchids and,
and how they're treated and how bad it is for them to be trapped in these
environments and how their dorsal fins go limp because they never have to deal
with current.
So the atrophy,
the whole thing,
it's sick.
It's sick.
Do they still have them now and killer whales at sea world now?
Yes.
Yeah,
they still have them.
they,
they can't,
they can't buy new ones apparently or something like that.
There's some weird,
fantastic,
yeah,
the whole thing.
They can't,
they think they could still breed them though.
I mean,
the whole thing is fucked up,
man.
It's,
it's just like slavery.
If like we had aliens as slaves,
we just couldn't.
We were like,
what are you saying?
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know what you're saying,
dude.
Get in the pool.
If you want to fish it,
getting the fucking pool.
I mean,
that's basically what's going on.
It's gross.
Yeah,
it's,
it's sick.
It's twisted,
you know?
And I just,
uh,
so that's where me and Pete were on the same page.